I'm joined today by dr. Jenny Harris the
deputy chief medical officer and
professor Stephen Paris the medical
director of NHS England I'd like first
to update you all on the facts about the
spread of covered 19 and the steps that
we are then taking in the battle against
this virus one hundred and forty three
thousand one hundred and eighty six
people have now been tested for the
virus of those twenty five thousand one
hundred and fifty have tested positive
and sadly yesterday we recorded the
highest single increase in the number of
deaths as a result of covered 19 381
people died
meaning that of those hospitalized in
the UK the number who have passed away
now totals 1789 every death is the loss
of a loved one and our thoughts and
prayers are with those who are grieving
over all ten thousand seven hundred and
sixty-seven people in England have been
admitted to hospital with coffered 19
symptoms the largest number of those is
in London with three thousand nine
hundred and fifteen people in hospital
care while in the Midlands the number of
those hospitalized is now 1918 and
accelerating upwards these numbers
reinforce the vital importance of
following the government's social
distancing guidelines the more we
restrict contact the more we slow the
spread of the infection the more that we
can help the NHS build the capacity
needed to care for those most in need
and that capacity is increasing more NHS
staff are returning to the frontline and
more testing is taking place to help
those self isolating come back and to
protect those working so hard in our
hospitals and in social care but though
the rate of testing is increasing we
must go further faster a critical
constraint on the ability to rapidly
increase testing capacity is the
availability of the chemical reagents
which are necessary in the testing
the Prime Minister and the health
secretary are working with companies
worldwide to ensure that we get the
material we need to increase tests of
all kinds and as well as increasing the
number of staff on the front line and
the tests which protect them we must
also increase the capacity to provide
oxygen to those worst affected by the
disease we have just over 8,000
ventilators deployed in NHS hospitals
now this number has increased since the
epidemic began thanks to the hard work
of NHS professionals but we need more
that's why we are buying more
ventilators from abroad including from
EU nations and it's also why we're
developing new sources of supply at home
before the epidemic struck we had very
little domestic manufacture of
ventilators but now thanks to the
dedication of existing medical supply
companies and the ingenuity of our
manufacturing base we have existing
models being produced in significantly
greater numbers and new models coming on
stream orders have been placed with
consortium led by Ford Airbus the
Formula One racing teams including
McLaren GKN aerospace and rolls-royce
and Dyson's and I can announce that this
weekend the first of thousands of new
ventilator devices will roll off the
production line and be delivered to the
NHS next week from there they will be
rapidly distributed to the frontline and
as well as increasing the capacity for
ventilation which helps support those
patients worst-affected were also
increasing the capacity to provide
oxygen to affected patients at an
earlier stage in the process of the
disease helping to avert we hope the
deterioration of their condition a team
led by UCL working with mercedes-benz
will produce 10,000 new CPAP devices to
support affected patients and a team
from Oxford University are also
developing related to technology and in
our determination to prevent as many
patients as possible seeing their
condition worsen we are conducting rapid
clinical trials on those drugs including
antimalarials which may be able to
reduce the impact of
covered 19 on those affected but even as
we seek to explore every Avenue to slow
the spread of the disease to reduce its
impact and to save lives unconscious of
the sacrifices that so many are making
that's why the Chancellor's economic
package is in place to support people
through a difficult time it's also why
we are working so closely with our
colleagues in the devolved
administration's to coordinate our
response across the United Kingdom I'm
grateful to them as I am to the
thousands of dedicated public sector
workers cleaners and social workers
prison and police officers those in the
Royal Mail and in our schools and I want
to thank them and also the leaders of
the trade unions who represent in this
united national effort we're also
delivering food and prescription drugs
to up to 1.5 million of the most
vulnerable for self isolating for three
months and we will do more to help
working with the three-quarters of a
million people who volunteered to help
at this time many are already heavily
involved in local community support
schemes and we want to work with them do
we to ensure that we support not just
the 1.5 million most vulnerable to the
disease but all those who need our help
through this crisis those without social
support those in tough economic
circumstances those who need the visible
hand of friendship at a challenging time
that's why my cabinet colleague George
Eustace and the food and farming
Minister Victoria Prentice will be
leading work with food suppliers
retailers local authorities and
voluntary groups to support our
neighbors in need I also want to thank
the men and women of the military who
stepped up their work as part of the
ongoing response to coronavirus three
RAF puma helicopters are now stationed
at kinloss barracks and marie these
Pumas are working closely with a Chinook
and a worldcat helicopter based at RAF
leaming in North Yorkshire to meet
requests for assistance from NHS boards
and trusts across Scotland and Northern
England a second helicopter facility
covers the Midlands and
southern England working out of the
aviation task force headquarters at RAF
Benson in Oxfordshire chinook and
worldcat helicopters normally based at
RAF odium and RNAs yo volton
respectively support for southern areas
and these helicopter facilities have
been set up to support medical transport
across Scotland and the rest of the
United Kingdom the task force is also
available for general support such as
moving equipment and personnel to where
they are needed across the United
Kingdom and the Kinloss based sport
follows the use of an RAF a 400m
transport aircraft working with the
Scottish Ambulance Service to evacuate a
critically ill patient from the Shetland
Islands to Aberdeen to receive intensive
care treatment and deeply grateful for
everyone in the Armed Forces and in the
public sector for doing so much to help
us in the fight against coronavirus and
of course all of us can continue to play
our part in supporting them and the
Health Service by staying at home
supporting the NHS and saving lives now
I want to ask Steven to run through the
latest data from our Cabinet Office
coronavirus fact file Steven thank you
so our incredible staff in the NHS are
working round-the-clock pulling out all
the stops to prepare for the expected
surge in patients with Kovac 19:00 I saw
that myself at the NHS Nightingale
Hospital in East London this morning and
was completely bowled over by the work
that is being done there from a standing
start a week ago to a new hospital that
will be ready to take patients later
this week but as we have repeatedly said
and as you have just heard NHS staff
cannot do this on their own yes we can
increase capacity but we also need
everybody in the country every one of
you to help by reducing the transmission
of the virus because it is by doing that
that we will reduce the number of deaths
and we will take the pressure off our
hospitals and our health system and the
charts that
about to show you will show you why that
is so important so all the interventions
all the instructions that the government
have given based on the best possible
scientific advice and similar to the
approach being taken in many countries
around the world are designed to reduce
social contact in other words to reduce
the chance that a virus the virus is
passed from one person to another and by
doing that the spread of the virus
reduces and the number of infections
reduces I'm pleased to say that the
great British public are paying
attention to that message and we see in
many ways that that amount of social
contact is now reducing so this first
chart shows you an example of that
transport and as you can see the number
of people using our transplant services
has reduced dramatically over the last
few weeks so for example you can see in
the light blue line that transport in
London on the tube has decreased
dramatically which demonstrates that
people are paying attention and
understand the message we are giving and
there are many other examples that show
that that contact is being reduced as
the next chart shows that plays into an
impact on the number of infections so
the less social contact the less the
chance is that the virus can move from
one person to another and that will over
time reduce the number of infections
that we are seeing the number of people
testing positive and you can see here
that we have had a rise in the number of
new UK cases but recently there is a
little bit of a plateau now I think it's
really important not to read too much
into this because it's early days we're
not out of the woods we're very much in
the woods and it's really important that
we keep complying with those
instructions but as you can see the
number of infections is not rising as
rapidly as it was so green shoots but
only green shoots and we must not be
complacent and we must not take our foot
off the pedal
now if infections fall as the next chart
shows that will also translate
into fewer hospital admissions hospital
admissions typically occur a week or two
after an infection and remember for the
vast majority of people kovat 19 is a
mild flu-like illness a heavy cold but
for a small percentage of people
hospitalization is required now you can
see here that the rate of
hospitalization has been increasing and
we would expect that at this stage in
the epidemic but if those infections
start to drop then in the next few weeks
our hope is that the number of
hospitalizations will also start to
reduce now the good news here is that
that line is not going up very steeply
but it is still rising we're not out of
the woods we need to keep our foot on
the pedal and as you can see there
around a third of the hospital
admissions are in London because as we
have said and as we know the infection
is spreading more rapidly in London and
London is a bit ahead of the rest of the
country in terms of this epidemic now as
the next chart shows hospitalization
unfortunately some people who
hospitalized do die every death is
tragic and we absolutely need to avoid
as many deaths as possible by all
playing our part so what we want to see
over time is a reduction in the number
of deaths and you can see here a
comparison of deaths in different
countries and you can see maybe in the
very light line in the middle that china
over time has flattened that particular
line in other words the number of deaths
have reduced and so if we reduce a
number of infections we will reduce the
number of hospitalizations and we will
reduce the number of deaths maybe some
green shoots but the last thing I would
want is a message to anybody that this
is a time to take our foot off the pedal
to not comply with the instructions
because this is not a short haul as
we've said this is going to take time
and it's important that we all stick
with it everybody thank you